so a little bit of an update as to what
the studios are currently up to you may
or may not have heard that the amptp
which is the organization that the
writers and the actors are striking
against has hired a PR firm in
particular the one they've hired is
known for crisis management and one of
the immediate questions I see people
asking is wait you don't have the money
to give the writers and actors what
they're asking for but you can afford
this but yeah of course they can because
I don't think I've made this clear it's
not about the money
it never has been
they will happily spend as much as it
would have cost them to meet the writers
and actors demands on trying to stop
them because it's not about money it's
about power and it's about control they
do not want to feel as if they have lost
some of their control of the industry
and of how things are run and they will
pay more than it would cost them to
settle with the unions in order to hold
on to that control
they're still going to break though